cost of prescription drugs by building
infrastructure of America in a green way
and in doing so increasing paychecks
lower health care bigger paycheck
cleaner government not even going to get
a vote again public sentiment is
everything President Lincoln the Senate
will certainly be hearing from the
public on issues values really that that
have bipartisan support across America
this is our attempt to find our common
ground so many of these issues whether
it's gun safety or violence against
women in the rest ranked very high
across the board across party across
party lines right now I'm very proud
that on the floor of the house as a
former appropriator appropriations
committee is putting forth a legislation
that reflects our values to meet the
needs of American people already we're
we addressed issues I've raising the
funding for the National Institutes of
Health investing further in early
childhood education we are talking about
nothing that's in rosa DeLauro s bill
Health and Human Services and education
legislature legislation we heard from
mr. Visclosky on the defense bill so
we're talking about a strong America
strong in our national security our
national defense and strong in the
health and education and well-being of
the American people I would love just to
read to you all the provisions of the
legislation but they're there for you to
see and we'll be talking about them
enlarging those issues as to what they
mean to the American people so that is
part of our legislate investigate
litigate agenda we're doing this and at
the same time we are honoring our oath
of office to protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States
yesterday the president gave us once
again evidence that he does not know
right from wrong it's a very sad thing
very sad thing but he just not know
right from wrong I believe that he has
been involved in a criminal cover-up
I've said that before and our
investigation is demonstrating that the
molder report showed obstruction of
justice intent at least ten perhaps
eleven places but for the president to
be so cavalier to disregard to be
indifferent to all and any sense of
ethics about who we are as a country to
say he would invite for an intervention
further the intelligence community with
great confidence is put forth that the
Russians interfered interfered in our
election that's an assault on our
democracy an assault on our democracy
this president says it's a hoax he
supposed that he takes an oath to
protect and defend the Constitution but
I guess it doesn't include him in terms
of being to be held accountable to obey
the law so we haven't a package that
we're putting forth in light of the
model report a package of legislation
Duty report someone comes to a mandating
that campaigns report foreign op offers
of assistance it shouldn't even I mean
it's so self-evident as a matter of
ethics but we'll have to codify it
mandating a duty to report for campaign
of campaigns reporting foreign
interventions in our elections
protecting our elections with paper
ballot that's our election security bill
that Zola Finn is working on and she is
working with the Senate hoping to have
bipartisan support in the house for our
legislation to protect our electoral
system our closing foreign money
loopholes that's mr. sarbanes bill post
the Moller report and mr. here mr.
Thompson will be having a hearing in the
Homeland Security Committee about
preventing foreign disinformation that
is just a sample of some of the things
that will we'll be out there
I believe we're making good progress on
oversight our our chairmen are doing a
great job I'm so proud of them the
winning in the courts and winning
documents from the Justice Department
with the thought of contempt for
following up on subpoenas and we're
going to get the truth for the American
people so that they can know what this
what the attack is on our country
what the president refused to do about
it and what he engaged in to cover up
what was done there's so many things
happened I just want to refer to one
thing in Hong Kong as many of you know
or some of you do anyway the issue of
China has been an important one for me
since Tiananmen Square even before but
in terms of public policy here in the
Congress in stanvan Square and on June
4th we celebrated the 30th anniversary
of the massacre and chandaman Square at
the same time we're observing that the
Chinese government is engaged in
arresting millions of we guards and
putting them into education camps that
they are diminishing the democracy in
Hong Kong trying to really just
eliminate the culture the language the
religion in Tibet the list goes on and
on but right now currently as we gather
here in Hong Kong as you know the last
few days hundreds of thousands if not a
million people gathered in the street to
protest an extradition law that the
Chinese government wants the the Hong
Kong government to pass it's such an
horrible danger horribly dangerous piece
of legislation I'm very pleased to be
supporting legislation that Senator
Marco Rubio and Chris Smith on the
Republican side Jim McGovern died on our
side and others are putting forth to
improve and modernize the Hong Kong US
relations at us Hong Kong
Asians act and that is going to be
submitted today they're just finalizing
it helps being submitted today but this
is this is so wrong and I do hope that
the president will speak about human
rights in China and the freedoms in
China when he talks about trade with the
Chinese I am pleased of a secretary
Pompeo statement on what's happening in
China now in this regard but that'll
take me questions what we're saying it
should be it's against the law it's so
against any sense of decency
but let me give you an example perhaps
you don't know this or maybe you do but
to remind in 2000 when the race was
between senator Gore and and governor
governor Bush
Tom Downey a former member of Congress
close friend of Al Gore was playing
George Bush in the press in the debate
prep and somebody threw over the transom
under the door whatever place it came
the plans for the Bush campaign in the
debates in the debates they just got
that - Tom Downey he picked it up and
sent it to the FBI this is even foreign
governments doesn't even foreign
government that's what you do there is a
sense of decency about fruit from the
forbidden tree ill-gotten gain about
what again how president of it then
Governor Bush would have conducted that
debate this is this is so and and just
by dint of your question with all due
respect you make it sound as if it could
be a common thing it is not and what the
president said last night shows clearly
once again over and over again that he
does not go with the difference between
right and wrong and that's probably the
nicest thing I can say about
because if he doesn't know the
difference that could explain some of
his ridiculous behavior and now to
invite further involvement of foreign
governments into our election there was
an assault on our democracy and assault
on our country by the Russians that has
been clearly documented by the
intelligence community and the President
of the United States and said coming to
the defense of our our democracy has
said it's a hoax
this is beyond I mean it's really there
is no sense of what's the word I wanted
to find a any ethical sense that that
informs his comments and his thinking
there is there is in the law that you
cannot accept contributions and that
includes in-kind from a foreign your
campaign cannot from a foreign
government that is in the wall but if it
needs more clarity then we will go the
duty to report that's not that's phony
you don't accept it but you report it to
the FBI because this is it's an invasion
of our democracy so I don't have a
language right here but there is
language in the law that prohibits any
contribution and again contribution is
in-kind information or whatever that is
but we want to make sure that has more
clarity and carries a responsibility to
report has nothing to do with any
campaign I make sure I want you to all
to understand that as we go down this
path to seek the truth for the American
people and to hold the president
accountable it has nothing to do with
politics or any campaigns it has
everything to do if I may excuse me
answer your question it has everything
to do with patriotism not partisanship
so we as we collect all the facts and it
takes time because you have to do your
research make your request you go to
court you have to do the accommodation
you know what that is it takes time to
prove that you have try to resolve the
issue and that takes time and that's the
path that we will be and it accomplishes
and in all of the
comments that the president has made to
clarify though why don't women in the
front I'm so excited about that
[Laughter]
why if the president is inviting foreign
interference why is that